[Musique]
la nourriture certains gamins aime les
voitures des vêtements chers les elfi
d'argent j'ai découvert que j'aimais la
nourriture
[Musique]
non le brahms la mono des biens acquis
m'appelle abraham d'autres ibrahim mais
je préfèrerais ben
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
qu'est ce que tu veux je peux vous file
un coup de main on n'a pas besoin de
rentrer chez toi
[Musique]
j'aimerais pouvoir cuisiner quelque
chose qui est ni qui rapproche les gens
que vous le faites vous pouvait
m'apprendre j'aurai besoin d'un petit
coup de main
tous
c'est un ramé tac au tac aux avec des
nids
fehim tu mélanges fusion est confiant
tu fais la porte
[Musique]
personne ne comprend ce que je traverse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peut-être que la génération
trouvailles en sorte autorités
on choisit pas sa famille
[Musique]